[Applause]
this crowd's insane
i'm actually fearing for my life
i need to be escorted to the hello pad
immediately
well happy monday everyone
so
let's uh we'll save the trump stuff for
the b block but today tonight what's
with all the people eating bugs
first you remember this crackpot
are you ready cheers actually i'm less
scared of this okay
oh the crunch
[Music]
do you have a wing hanging out of my
mouth
i hope it's a wing
you never know it's cnn
but why'd they pick her anyway i can
think of someone else at cnn who needs
to be restricted to eating just bugs
uh low-hanging fruit but now in recent
years everyone's getting into the act
even celebrities do you want to share a
spider
can i make
it's actually really good the flavor
corn worms
they're still alive
[Music]
extraordinary it's ants
these are crickets from mexico from
oaxaca is it weird to just go with oh
yeah let's go for
[Applause]
unlike his ratings
he's gone who cares
but they could even act like they
enjoyed it and a lot of them were actors
of course now some claim that you should
be eating insects in order to reduce
carbon emissions
this is a powder derived from the
mealworm and it's a insect protein just
been approved by the eu
for human consumption the making of it
is severely reducing the the amount of
emissions it takes if we make this
switch it's a huge huge uh intervention
i'm pretty sure that guy sat next to me
on a greyhound bus in 1989.
he was telling him about how his voices
were telling him to go to i don't know
to go eat insects so now it's a moral
obligation
to eat insects but like eating a
centipede they're just playing the long
game right
i didn't write that
if you if you laughed i would take
ownership of it but uh we just fired
that person first they're gonna tell you
that eating insects isn't at all weird
then they're gonna tell you it's normal
to eat insects and then finally you're
racist if you don't eat insects
so yahoo yahoo remember that yahoo
actually wrote a fact check piece
claiming eating insects isn't harmful
i'm going to quote this social media
posts say that chitin contained an
insect exo exoskeleton cannot be
processed by the human body this is
misleading while some parts of insects
may not be digested entirely by humans
it doesn't mean that eating them is
harmful
i don't know i think those experts are
full of chit
so
maybe not every bug makes you sick but
if i've got worms in my stomach
take me to the hospital
and don't suggest that they need company
now others will say bugs are part of a
balanced diet in other countries as well
as being integral to the culture
which explains why people live there to
come here
if insects are integral to your culture
you need to find a new culture
if i was working in immigration and a
refugee came to my desk and i asked why
are you here and they said my family
eats insects
i'd wave them all through
bugs are carriers of disease and
parasites the texture is disgusting no
one smiles when they eat insects
and when robert downey jr says it will
reduce emissions yeah but by what
one study found that if every american
became vegetarian emissions would drop
by only five percent that's not worth it
baptists most people eat meat because
it's healthy and as michael
shellenberger author of the book
apocalypse never points out the amount
of pollution from farming is trivial
compared to jet setting around the world
promoting bug cuisine
so
yeah
and so what if it's popular in other
countries you know what else is popular
in other countries b headings
which is also good for the climate
because it cuts down on exhaling which
in turns cuts down co2 levels
should we adopt that practice too being
headless makes it more difficult to
drive helping the environment as well
that's the point though
it's not it's not about your health or
your taste buds it's about climate the
bbc asks could grasshoppers really
replace beef well here's the long answer
no
the writer
is standing over swearing
the writer said he was intrigued to see
how he could lower his carbon footprint
if he ate bugs as his main source of
protein well you do that champ
and also be sure and write another piece
when you stop making insects your main
source of protein
that'll be two days later when you're
riding it from a hospital bed
so why all this media lockstep once
again it's driven by people who exempt
themselves from their own advice do you
think these elites will eat bugs
themselves do you think greta
thundberg's mom packed her centipede
sandwich in her hello kitty lunchbox
this morning
do you think you're gonna see cream of
carpenter ant as a dinner special at the
u.n cafeteria
no when they asked who ordered bugs at
the world economic forum all you hear is
crickets
uh you would have used that joke
[Applause]
i'll take it
you see the faces of people who eat
insects it's revulsion
and revulsion is an instinct the humans
who didn't find eating insects revolting
died
that's why we prefer our food insect
free because we're the ones left
sure you could say but it's low fat but
so is dog
and i'm not smearing that across a bagel
i told kill meat it was nutella
but really
what really sucks what really sucks and
the whole point of this is that they
ignore the main reason that humans eat
bugs it's because they're poor and they
don't have access to better food so
instead these fools try to make poverty
seem like fun i mean do you think an
african child would eat a plate of meal
worms if they could have a bowl of pesto
instead of pests
like president biden bugs are no one's
first choice
they leave that part out of every story
the lack of prosperity that forces them
to eat insects like the president's bms
it's not voluntary
i left that in there and i'm still
wondering why
then they call uh something people eat
out of desperation a delicacy by this
logic the donner party was a 12 course
lesson in exotic cuisine
don't knock it
but it's all about manufacturing consent
getting us to adopt a practice that
advocates won't take part in like giving
up their personal jet or putting giant
windmills in their backyards the world
economic forum may push this stuff but
they're not eating spiders which by the
way are now our competition for the
insects they're better at it look we've
all eaten insects before too but usually
by accident
i just swallowed the
[Applause]
i'm beef he's down here buzzing around
right now man he went right down the
hatch
um he didn't seem to enjoy that he must
be a bigot
doesn't appreciate other cultures
but do you really think americans are
gonna eat beetles when we get lobster
tail at the sunuko station
fact is restaurants that have bugs on
the menu are only because some dude used
the menu to swat a fly
sorry my idea of a buffet isn't standing
under a bug light catching what falls
onto my plate
but this isn't about you it's not about
the rich really they aren't giving up
their foie gras for fried worm
it's not about targeting the middle
class either the closest they'll come to
eating a bug is the bee in apple bees
the only people left really are the poor
so is that where we're headed feeding
bugs and mass to the poor instead of
helping them out of poverty i'm jealous
of the days when elite said let him eat
cake
now it's let him eat cicadas
[Applause]
welcome tonight's guests
other than shields brothers in babbling
she's my favorite brook human rights
lawyer and award-winning filmmaker and
author brooke goldstein
[Applause]
when the fbi raided his closet there was
nothing worth taking fox across america
host jimmy fella
musician writer director producer lawyer
host other than that he's accomplished
nothing
producer director joe escalante
and finally she's like a matchstick
slender and ready to get lit fox news
contributor cat tip
so jimmy yep uh i would make a comment
about miami vice but we've been down
that road
this is actually jacksonville vice i
wasn't cute enough to make miami vice
yeah but like down the road a few
hundred miles chubbs exactly
i was going to ask you if you've eaten
bugs on purpose
and you cannot count the ones you find
on your body or in your clothing
never by choice i mean if people want to
eat bugs here in the city there's a lot
of restaurants that serve them you can
tell because they have a d in the window
from the board of health you know what i
mean
it's so it's every rationale for doing
this like you said is a scam okay yes
they're you know pushing the poverished
lifestyle of other countries onto us but
even when they say like oh it's like
what the cavemen did yo the cavemen
lived to be 21 right you know what i'm
saying
i don't know that we should be adopting
any of their practices
but like that's the whole scam again and
again and again is that they're leaving
out the fact that this is an
options-based issue nobody buys a
blow-up doll because they're just
cleaning up with the ladies you know
what i'm saying
that's a good analogy
they still make those jimmy
ask asking for a friend of course
i just love that with everything going
on in the news you opened on eating bugs
is it cattle rancher week on gutfeld
like i loved it
and we did that story every single night
no you're right i loved it and i know
this is personal for you because you're
the same size as ant-man
that would be one
let's go to one let's go to somebody
with a brain
brooke you are a human's human rights
lawyer that's right that's right
violation oh it is
i just find this so creepy and so
elitist okay and it's creepy because
they're not even hiding this
coordination between the eu coming out
then there's the world economic forum
and then all of a sudden overnight
forbes and and bloomberg and nature
magazine and science magazine and then
the government announces a meat tax
yes right that meat tax might be coming
they're like forcing this notion on us
and it's so ridiculous and elitist and
you mentioned
i even saw an article statistics saying
something like well 70 percent of people
in africa eat bugs that is not by choice
and if you put a
child down who is in africa and you put
a bug and a burger in front of that
child i guarantee you that child is
going to go for the burger and then the
last point is this
pro-bug cancel culture that has come out
overnight where you are being attacked
if you say something that is totally
factual like 81 percent of bugs carry
parasites that are harmful to humans i'm
not giving this to my children
you know what's interesting though i see
their point that if a bug is carrying
another bug you get twice the benefit
so like we think like oh my god i have a
parasite but if a bug has a parasite
it's like you just got 30 percent free
it's like getting it's like two scoops
of raisins
oh don't remember that
but i love the fact that you like you
listed all the media because it it's
that's the weird thing joe
is that at all i like to do that so you
get ready then i'm ready
i could tell you were nodding off in
your little
mr rogers sweater no but it's like
it was all those videos they're not
recent during the last five years but
all the stuff came out in the last two
weeks as meat got more expensive it's
the same logic they're using on fossil
fuels natural gas they want to price it
out so you go to the windmills in this
case they want us to eat bugs
well if you i mean the part of mexico
where my family uh came from they don't
eat bugs i mean it's just certain parts
of mexico where there's like yeah oh
should i do a correction yeah it's it's
called yeah the human centipede can i
offend you by i didn't even mention
mexico
well i'm just saying that that was
what's her face it's on your face it's
on my ticket
when they said mexico you looked at me
and said huh huh yeah what did you do it
was sam hayek was that somehow that was
eaten like a critter yeah yes thank you
the producer yeah so apologize to me i
will i apologize for your racism
but um these bobby you know the the
restaurants even the restaurants in
mexico where they eat the bugs um they
don't serve you a bunch of bugs and and
expect you to be full they you've got a
pound of carnitas and then they sprinkle
some you know chapolines on them little
grasshoppers around the side to make you
feel hip
but in the end the way they cook them
they just end up tasting it's like a
donut it just ends up tasting like the
the kind of whatever kind of ketchup you
put on it right right but the problem is
i don't see any ketchup in any of this
no well you know they'll get there yes
they'll find out soon enough soon enough
they'll find out and then everything
changes right ketchup changes everything
mm-hmm right it's like the internet for
food
pat how are you
i'm all right
just all right well when you saw this as
a topic what did you think finally we're
gonna attack the whole bug industry the
brainwashing yeah i i just you know
i guess we've gotten over the whole
cultural appropriation thing
exactly
haven't we been hearing for years that
taking anything from another culture is
cultural appropriation
and now if they've changed their minds
you're like no if you just take the real
stuff it's okay
that it's like oh you better not wear
some brown i can't open it but you want
to get your bike
yeah i could not open like a taco stand
but i but if it's all bugs then i'm good
yes i think they're funking the climate
people because none of the people giving
this advice follow it like you're saying
they all fly in private jets but tell
you to fly coach i think they're in john
kerry's jet laughing their asses off
like dude people are eating bugs right
now like they're listening to the
beatles while you're eating the beatles
you know what i'm saying
it's so dumb
that was like you had that joke in your
[ __ ] you're right
i'm so happy that you got it get a
chance to do it okay i need to throw it
out there
all right no it's okay i appreciate it
gotta laugh
that's what's why is everybody so
sensitive
what bug is up your ass
what is what's gone wrong
this is fox news
up next law enforcement gets cam's
endorsement
hey sean hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to fox news youtube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else